premier coup de sécateur sur cette
parcelle de sauvignon la région de
Sancerre a battu des records de
température pour un mois de septembre
alors il faut récolter vite avant que la
vigne ne soit grillée par le soleil et
les raisins trop chargés en sucre
vous voyez la le soleil l'impact qui
commence à avoir et commence un petit
peu à
brûler flétrir le raisin il en train de
se déshydrater donc on va aller sur une
trop grande concentration donc là il est
temps de les ramasser les pépins sont
bien il y a encore l'acidité du
sauvignon sans que ce soit encore trop
tropical car le millésime 2023 s'annonce
exceptionnelle sur ses 33 hectares
plantés en Sauvignon et Pinot Noir le
viticulteur a bénéficié d'une
météoridéale
je suis rentré en 2011 j'ai rarement
connu aussi beau avec une quantité qui
est bien homogène partout il y a pas de
trop de vigne qu'on souffert de la
sécheresse comme un 22 on n'a pas eu le
gel de 2021 non là
si le soleil se calme un peu tous les
feux sont au vert
et pour miser encore plus sur la qualité
Matthieu Delaporte a choisi depuis 2015
devant danger à la main mais il a besoin
d'une centaine de personnes alors il
fait appel à de la main d'oeuvre
étrangère comme Serkan bulgare qui
découvre le métier de vendangeur
c'est un peu dur de travailler car il
fait très chaud et le travail n'est pas
facile
tous de travailler vite et de rester
positif
et en attendant la baisse des
températures le travail démarre plutôt
le matin et le rafraîchissement plus
régulier dans la journée
des vendanges de plus en plus précoces
hier les premiers coups de sécateurs ont
également été donnés dans le Bordelais
pour les vins rouges avec une semaine
d'avance sur le calendrier habituel la
faute au réchauffement climatique toutes
les régions viticoles sont concernées
Florent Boutet
et oui c'est vendanges c'est vrai elles
sont toujours plus précoces et ça c'est
l'Observatoire français de la
biodiversité qui nous le dit regardez ce
chiffre en moyenne sur le vignoble
français c'est 18 jours plus tôt par
rapport à ces 40 dernières années il y a
même des disparités régionales en Alsace
28 jours plus tôt presque un mois
rendez-vous compte en Champagne 21 jours
plus tôt deux semaines plus tôt sur le
Bordelais le Saint-Emilion par exemple
et puis en descendant sur les rivages de
la Méditerranée pour le Tavel le
Châteauneuf-du-Pape c'est à peu près le
même ordre de grandeur 13 jours plutôt
alors si on récolte ces petites grappes
en avance et bien c'est corrélé
directement avec la chaleur autrement
dit le changement climatique à court
terme il n'y a pas que des effets
négatifs ça augmente la maturité ça la
rend plus rapide donc et bien il y a
priori plus de rendement le taux
d'alcool est aussi plus fort dans le vin
que l'on déguste et il y a moins de
risques de maladies dans les vignobles
seulement voilà il y a aussi des effets
négatifs si cette chaleur s'accompagne
d'un manque d'eau d'une sécheresse ça
fait baisser drastiquement les volumes
et puis ça peut accentuer le risque
d'orage plus fort et donc de grêle des
dégâts dans les vignes voilà pourquoi
certaines maisons de champagne par
exemple on choisit de se diversifier de
planter des vignes dans le Kent en
Angleterre comme Taittinger nous avons
la chance nous dit-il de bénéficier du
réchauffement climatique qui donne la
possibilité d'avoir des rendements
satisfaisants